like even the whole Rule and exception
there's all it's not one size fits all
it's really not where there is that's it
there are some men who Thrive and
succeed because they're a man because
life is easy therefore I'd be like I
would expect you okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you an example my dad's the
half top half a percentage of earners
okay he's the white man right that but
but here's the thing he worked 80 hours
a week my whole life I didn't I didn't
get to see him yeah how is that like the
patriarchy when my dad put in 80 hours
every week his whole life from the time
I was like a child right missed a lot a
lot of a lot of like he earned that
yeah and I'm never gonna say that's like
no the patriarchy anyway but now now
he's a white male CEO yeah right so is
is that the patriarchy or did women not
choose to do that well that's